bonsoir antoine coypel merci d'être avec
nous ce soir alors première question
dans quel état d'esprit se trouve pour
l'instant la police bonsoir pierre des
remontées que j'ai soit des syndicats
soit des policiers de terrain
l'inquiétude a fait place à la colère
dans un premier temps des chances
février puis le 4 mars il ya eu des
sachets s'étaient organisés à beauvau
pour prendre en main la question du
coronavirus de la protection des
policiers
déjà à l'époque il ya une quinzaine de
jours ils s'inquiétaient de savoir
comment leurs l'accueil sera organisée
dans les commissariats notamment et il
constaté qu'il n'avait pas de masque pas
de gants pas de gel hydroalcoolique
donc ça c'était l'inquiétude et petit à
petit on leur a dit de ne plus porter
les masques
puis on leur a dit qu'ils pouvaient les
porter et puis à nouveau à présent les
ans leur en laisse en fait on leur
retire carrément les masques pour les
redistribuer dans les hôpitaux
enfin ils doivent les doivent leur
donner à la grèce les agences régionales
de santé
donc là c'est la grosse colère en fait
ce soir il ya eu il ya des nouveaux
communiqués qui sont en train de se
préparer au sein des syndicats et qui
sortiront demain
selon mes dernières informations de ce
soir et qui vont faire part de la très
grande colère des forces de l'ordre qui
doivent sortir contrôler les gens et
alors que des syndicats comme l'unsa à
présent appel à ne plus le faire
pas de protection pas de contrôle à deux
pas de verbalisation antoine sont les
politiques qui continuent sur le sur le
terrain comment font-ils pour se
protéger alors les policiers que j'ai pu
avoir donc notamment un fonctionnaire
qui travaille dans un commissariat
d'ile-de-france en zone un peu sensible
m'a dit que pour sa part il s'était
débrouillé en fait avec les collègues
il ya le chef de brigade en fait qui
s'est arrangé pour qu'ils aient des
masques donc un kit par jour les gants
le gel les masques un kit par jour par
fonctionnaire à chaque sortie en fait à
chaque prise de service
ça c'est au cas par cas en fait ça
dépend des commissariats pour le moment
malheureusement bon si on leur demande
de toute façon de les restituer aux ars
semblerait donc je ne sais pas si ça va
continuer par ailleurs ils essayent de
laisser les portes ouvertes dans les
commissariats pour pas les toucher il
retire les retient les claviers et on
retient les souris ce genre de mesures
très simples mais qui permettent de
limiter la casse en fait pas ce qu'il ya
de plus en plus de policiers qui tombe
malade et qui sont confinés même donc on
va arriver à des taux des pourcentages
de fonctionnaires passe pas disponible
sur le terrain assez fort rapidement il
ya des crs qui ont déjà manifesté leur
volonté de faire valoir le droit de
retrait aussi donc si le gouvernement et
bovo en particulier souhaite voir
continuer les mesures de confinement est
le respect des mesures de confinement va
falloir trouver rapidement des solutions
pour les français n'y fait ce tenant
merci beaucoup antoine boitel d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir sur rtl france
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste ici
cherté france est spécialisée dans les
questions sécuritaires merci beaucoup